So we mentioned that a mobile user persona is
different than a web or desktop user persona. So I
think that a lot you might have started out
in web or desktop, so maybe we should start there.
>> Yeah, what are the attributes of this web or desktop persona?
>> Well the first thing is that there always going to be plugged into power.
>> Yeah.
>> They generally have a constant internet
connection that's usually fast. And generally they
have a pretty big screen. And they have some sort of physical keyboard and a
mouse or touch pen. And they're seated with their
full attention usually on their laptop or their desktop.
>> Yeah, and this is so different then
a mobile user because unlike mobile for web and
desktop applications. Let's say, you're writing a document or
you're working on a presentation, chances are. You're fully
immersed in the content that you're creating on
your machine. And another difference, actually, between web, and
desktop apps, and mobile apps. Is that when you
close a desktop app, they tend to go away.
Like you close a tab on your browser, but mobile
apps tend to run in the background quite a bit.
They're sensing your location, they've all kinds of sensors that
are providing input. And applications are doing something within the background